one of those guns is a 0.38 revolver
this was the gun that was responsible
for killing Olivia
the second gun is a Glock type self
loading nine millimeter pistol
this is what that weapon looks like
how can I I can now confirm that this
weapon has been used in a total of three
separate incidents across merseyside in
a two and a half year period
this includes the attack in Kings Heath
Avenue on the 22nd of August
that led to the murder of Olivia
guns that are used on more than one
occasion are referred to as link series
weapons
this gun is therefore a link series
firearm
this gun is linked series 179
and I want to provide some information
around link series 179
I'm showing you a map on the screen that
highlights the areas where this weapon
has been used
this Glock was first used in wimborne
close dovecott on the 27th of January
2020.
that is the image of the Red Square in
the top right of the map behind me
on that occasion a 19 year old man was
targeted and during that first incident
this resulted in an injury to him
furthermore and it's a shocking
similarity to the circumstances leaving
to Olivia's murder one of the bullets
also went through the front door of a
house of an innocent member of our
community
the attack could quite clearly have had
far more dire consequences had someone
been stood behind that door
this evidence is once again the callous
nature of those people in possession of
this weapon they have no regard for the
safety or the lives of anyone else they
do not deserve anyone's loyalty
the second incident happened on the 8th
of August
2022 and about 20 to 10 in the evening
this time in Finch way dovecott once
again and this is in the bottom
left-hand corner of the map behind me
you'll see that this is only a very
short distance from Olivia's home
address
on this occasion two rival gangs one in
a car others on a motorcycle
fired shots indiscriminately whilst near
to some playing fields
this occurred in the middle of summer in
an area where innocent local people
would have been enjoying the park
once again as with the first time this
weapon was used in our communities we
find that those in possession of it
have no care or thoughts or loyalty for
anyone else in that Community or for
their safety once again I reinforce the
message they do not deserve your loyalty
just two weeks later it was used in the
shooting at King's Heath Avenue along
with the 0.38 revolver which we now know
is responsible for the Fatal wounding of
little Olivia
these are incredibly dangerous weapons
that are in the hand or hands of people
that don't care about anyone else
therefore why should we or you show them
any loyalty at all
we know that one of these guns has been
used in three separate instances and I'm
determined to take these weapons off our
streets before they maim or kill again
looking at the locations as you will see
where this gun has been used on the map
it's very clear to me that their gun is
owned or controlled by an individual or
group of individuals in this immediate
area of dovecots
for the last two years it has been
exclusively used in this area
I would suggest therefore that this gun
is stored somewhere in this area and may
well still be there right now
I want people to tell us where those
guns are now
sadly and unbelievably during this
investigation I've been disgusted by a
small number of people
who are determined to thwart the
investigation
protect the individuals involved and try
and ensure that little Olivia and her
family do not receive the Justice they
deserve
this once again shows the type of people
that we are dealing with with this
inquiry
however they won't be successful and we
will prosecute them too
they involved with this gunman and
anything to do with this horrendous
matter will leave a stain on you for
life
I have no doubts that when you are
charged
and you will be charged and convicted
that you'll be regarded with absolute
disgust by your families your friends
and your communities
your loyalty to this man is utterly
misplaced and it will cost you
clearly the gunman doesn't want us to
find these guns
because it may link him back to them and
thereby to Olivia's murder
however
as I've said before in previous press
conferences this man is utterly toxic to
our communities
nobody wants this man around them or
indeed where they live
nobody wants to be associated with him
some people may tolerate him through
fear
but even those people given the choice
would want him locked away I am quite
sure with your support we can absolutely
make this happen
someone somewhere knows right now where
these weapons are hidden and I want to
know where they are so once again I'm
asking for your help in finding these
guns
I understand completely that people may
be reluctant or fearful to provide this
information to the police
and therefore and now on to appeal to
those people to listen very carefully
to what Mick Duffy from Crime Stoppers
is about to talk about
thank you Mark
firstly on behalf of everyone at Crime
Stoppers I wish to pass our deepest
condolences to the family and friends of
Olivia who've suffered such a terrible
loss
as a director of operations at the
charity Crime Stoppers I want to explain
how our charity helps keep communities
safe and allows people to pass
information to the police completely
anonymously
I'd also like to update you on our
reward offer
Crime Stoppers is an independent charity
we are not the police
or the BBC TV program
We Stand Alone to help keep communities
safe
giving people a safe option to speak up
about crime
our charity has been around for 35 years
in that time we've received from the
public
and passed to the police
millions of pieces of information
that have often helped solve
high-profile crimes and prevent others
from taking place
it's important for me to stress that
over all those decades Crime Stoppers
has kept our 100 anonymity guarantee
we never record calls
or ask for personal details
all incoming calls to us are scrambled
so we can never call you back
we don't use 1471 so we don't know who
you are
we never ask why you call or where you
are
all we want is for you to do the right
thing and give us your information
we note what you say
not who you are
we then make sure it contains nothing
that could possibly identify you
we then pass that information securely
and safely to police forces across the
UK
the police know that we can't give them
personal details about those contacting
us because we genuinely don't have that
in the first place
that anonymity protecting your identity
is Central to Crime Stoppers as a
charity and how we work for you
more and more people now contact us via
our website using a secure online
reporting form
this offers the same protection and
guarantee of anonymity that applies if
you call us
we will never get your IP address so we
can't come back to you or contact you or
pass details onto the police
if you do call us
your call will never be recorded on a
phone bill
we're extremely grateful to our founder
Lord Ashcroft for putting up the 50 000
pound reward
to encourage people to come forward and
we know that this is helping
like our phone
line and online reporting service our
rewards process is also completely
anonymous
you just need to request a reward code
when you contact us and more details of
the process can be found on our website
so to re reiterate you will always stay
Anonymous this applies when you pass
information on to us
and if your information leads to a
conviction or a recovery of a weapon say
you will stay Anonymous when claiming
and getting your reward
we never know who you are and therefore
the police will never know who you are
like everyone across the country we want
those responsible for the murder of
Olivia to be brought to Justice
and therefore today I can announce that
Lord Ashcroft has kindly raised his
offer from fifty thousand to one hundred
thousand pounds
on top of that
I want to announce that through the
generosity of another donor who wishes
to remain private at this time
we are raising our combined reward to
opt to two hundred thousand pounds
this reward is available for information
leading to the conviction of those
involved in Olivia's murder or other
Associated crimes including Firearms
offenses
to be eligible for this reward you must
contact Crime Stoppers
via our free phone number or 800 treble
five treble one
or visiting our website which is Crime
Stoppers hyphen uk.org
this reward the largest that Crime
Stoppers has ever been able to make is
being offered by our charity and not by
the police
so you can only claim the reward if you
come to us
we will then safely and securely pass
your information onto the police who
then can do their work
you will have done the right thing
you will have helped solve this
horrendous crime and prevented others
suffering
you can find out more by visiting our
Charities website which is Crime
Stoppers hyphen uk.org thank you